hi and welcome to the corridor cast
today's guest is Joe Penna who some of
you might know as mystery guitar man now
today's podcasts actually really
fascinating and personally one of my
favorites because Joe has made the
impossible jump the dream that we
dreamed that all of a stream and that is
to jump from YouTube into feature films
for Hollywood theatrical release to
feature films it's a heck of a journey
and he has just completed his first
journey with his movie Arctic which is
literally opening right now in theaters
so go check it out if you are by a
theater playing it because it's been
made by somebody who has dreamed the
dream and wanted to make this happen and
jumping over from YouTube to the world
of I guess Hollywood cinema is quite an
excursion and it's an interesting one
there's no other industry quite like it
so Joe is gonna share his perspective
his stories with us what it's like to
work with a Hollywood star Mads
Mikkelsen how do you get a Hollywood
star to listen to some youtuber as they
try to give you direction all these
fascinating stories and more on this
corridor cast stay tuned you made it man
you made the jump yeah trying to at
least yes so I guess to bring anyone up
to speed you hasn't paid attention
recently Joe Penna here used to be known
as mystery guitar man and wears glasses
all the time yeah oh yeah yeah back in
20 like 11 or 2012 the specific type
that I wear they they were gonna
discontinued them so I just bought like
a huge box oh wow and then so I still
have like a bunch of just nine around so
you were very successful on YouTube back
in the day mm-hmm a lot of great
different videos very like in visual
videos music based videos and you just
you crank them out which is nice the
radio which you put them out was pretty
impressive and you started making this
foray into narrative you put out a lot
of short films on your channel and this
is all kind of like you I feel like
prepping to make that dive and do
feature films uh-huh and just now you
your first theatrical feature film yeah
which is Arctic with Mads Mikkelsen yeah
so congratulations by the way thank you
but I think one of the big things is
that like our generation you know us you
Freddie and you know a bunch of the
other guys are kind of our age we had
all started YouTube because we wanted to
get into movies like to us it was like a
away there oh way to like hone our
skills and create an audience and like
prove to not just to the world but to
the producers and executives that
there's like hey look at me I can make a
film give me a budget yeah anyways here
here we are still doing YouTube videos
like but yeah I never wanted to get into
movies really yeah I heard an NPR
interview that I did like years and
years and years ago and the like I asked
me like the interviewer said would you
ever want to make a feature film and I
was like I I don't know if I can like
that's really it's so long it's like 35
days of shooting it's you know you're
devoting two or three years of your life
to one single project I think I'm too
ATD to do that yeah and yeah it was it
was something that slowly like came out
right I started with YouTube videos the
two minutes of frenzied action and and
insane and kind of like and in
interesting how that evolved in and of
itself you know it didn't used to be so
crazy until I did a collaboration with
Toby Turner mm-hmm Tobuscus back in the
day and he we were doing a thing we're
like I'm stop-motion edited on one side
and then he stopped motion editor on the
other side and he's just that at all
times you know he's like person at all
times and next to him like when we put
the footage literally side by side I
looked like I was a robot I got it I got
to bring the energy and that video did
so well that I was like I got to keep
the energy yeah but anyway so then I
started making out of that I started
making music videos so I did one for
Avicii I did one for a few other artists
and I started being like kind of forcing
them more and more to do the narrative
things
it was the thing at the time you know
lady Gaea did like five minutes of like
a little short film and then you hear
the music you know yeah yeah and then I
pitched the one of my artists like oh
let's do like a 20 minute long thing and
then I started pitching them the short
film that came before his music and he
just kind of raised his hand he's like
but like is this a music video where's
the music command like is it playing the
whole time I was like okay I got to
start making short films instead mm-hmm
yes then commercials short films and
then I did it like 40 minute long short
film and then it just kind of felt like
a natural jump to get to features you
know mm-hmm how many short films did you
make before you did arctic decent ones
like like legit big-budget like longer
than 10 minutes style yeah a couple of
them had to like be broken up into
series but I'll call those shorts still
four of them the very first one that it
was called once upon that was awful and
horrific and is unlisted from my youtube
channel and it was like kind of sort of
fantastical mystery guitar man lore kind
of thing okay um I I never want anyone
to see that ever then the next one that
it was called instant getaway with Ron
Howard and bran Grace's company that one
was the first one that I was like really
proud of and it was actually telling a
story it's like a sci-fi thing that is
if our world had teleporting like
nowadays you know the world is exactly
the same but I had teleporting in fact
they shot some of it right here yeah I
think we still have some you're
cardboard boxes there you go we brought
in a bunch of cardboard boxes because we
just needed it to looks like one that
had Tannersville Tanner Thompson yeah
yeah he wasn't that oh you guys yeah you
know it's it was fun because it was like
real you know I was like casting people
and I was producing things and it was
like you know I have to find locations
and it's like let's ask our friends and
and make it happen you know and it kind
of was YouTube plus mm-hmm
and then I was like okay I I can stand
to be behind the camera
so then I did another one called
turning-point and that was great which
was all a motion-control thing I really
wanted to do that was the creators of
Walking Dead had this wonderful set that
they donated to us and I was able to
shoot that in there we took that to
Tribeca that was great and then we did a
40-minute long short film that really
should have been a feature film like
this story is a little too compressed is
that the time-traveling yeah the
time-traveling one I really liked that
story yeah I really like called beyond
yeah I think it's I think it works you
know I think that so there's some great
acting and there's some wonderful like
match cuts and things like that that we
were trying but I would have rather had
a little bit more time to tell the story
and that's what what sold me on making a
feature film
I gotcha were these short films
strategic moves on your way to trying to
make a future film or were they just you
whine tell story beyond was beyond and
especially a turning point yes turning
point was not proof of concept for
Arctic but as a proof of ability yeah
yeah you know it was like we can do a
short film that's really visually
arresting that only has one person on
screen the entire time I can do that for
97 minutes trust me you know now did you
know about your desire to make Arctic
when you were making that film because
you just mentioned I'm making a film
with one person in it yeah this was
before Arctic ever became a thing it was
yeah it we had it was still called on
Mars back in the day him so so Arctic
initially was a sci-fi exactly the same
story but happening on a terraformed
Mars like a half there from Mars this
guy's plane crashes away from the the
colony on Mars and he needs to survive I
mean this instead of a helicopter that
comes to save him it's this like
quadcopter thing that we were gonna
build you know it's like it's the future
but anyway then the Martian came out and
ruined all of our play yeah so how did
you make the jump how did you how did
you get a film off the ground from where
you were on YouTube making shorts yeah
so so YouTube became less and less
viable for me as a full-time job
especially for me and my partner Ryan
Morrison right for the two of us to be
doing YouTube together in in living in
LA if it's really expensive and and
having a kid for me and and you know
trying to to make two full-time jobs
work out of that it wasn't working
anymore because my content really wasn't
working for what YouTube was you know it
needed to be longer it need to be more
often and I tried the the vlogging thing
it just I'm not that kind of guy
you know I'm not like off-the-cuff great
so I was like okay oh shoot I'm gonna
have to figure out what to do here I'm
either gonna have to find a job
somewhere or I'm gonna try to like push
on this feature film that my the agency
at the time wasn't really helping me
with and I didn't have a management
company at the time you know that did
feature films so I was like I'm gonna
pushing it myself but I want to try both
so I applied for a job at Google
Wow yeah I was gonna be working for the
YouTube spaces all around the world
traveling a bunch kind of creating
programs that that all these faces were
doing you know how sometimes they do
that it's like yeah yeah you know
sometimes it's related to a future film
and then the budget comes from that and
it's like the YouTube space in LA and
the one in Toronto and the one in Japan
they all are doing the same horror thing
you know yeah yeah it's all the month
yeah
so it was gonna be my job to come up
with those things gotcha okay and a lot
of traveling to figure out how to tweak
the program so though you know what in
Japan there are more vloggers so they
need to they need vlog sets that a
smaller set they don't need huge sets
you know in LA we need giant cameras you
know because he of they they can do that
here so so yeah you know that was that
was gonna be my job and I was like five
interviews in its free to get a job at
Google you have to like go through all
of these processes you know and and yet
was literally right before I was gonna
say yes to that job I heard that I had
at the same time been working on Arctic
I had been talking to this producer we
found a producer who had just that a
movie called mud bound mm-hmm and they
were like we're gonna fund your movie if
you find the right actor for us Wow and
we were like trying to go out to
different people
oh yeah so how do you get at how do you
find an actor how did that go you know
it we put a list together of people who
we thought it's a really small target
hit right it's got to be somebody who's
comfortable working with a first-time
director uh you know it's got to be
somebody who's got a big enough name to
command the budget that we had for the
film mm-hmm
okay so that's you've already outlined
two circles of a Venn diagram there just
barely overlap somebody who is can
physically pull this off yeah had to be
strong they have to be strong you know
and they somebody who's you know his got
to have enough international appeal
because this is gonna be an
international film so like who are we
gonna get that fits all of these things
you know in somebody who wants to do
this crazy like almost silent film we
put together a list you know and it was
like Shirley's their own Tom Hanks no
he's already done something similar and
you know people maybe who were like this
is what they're trying to do but they
haven't done it before so like Zac Efron
was on the list who is a to me is a
great actor he's just then this Ted
Bundy thing that's like doing really
well he's looking for something
different maybe him you know so this
wasn't so much a wish list as much as a
realistic yeah oh yeah wish list would
have had like you know okay yeah all the
Tom's name Tom but it was like a
realistic list you know and then
literally we had two different lists
they're like these are just actors who
we know we'll never get yeah but our are
great for the look for the etc right and
Mans was on the other list okay the list
with Tom Hanks and etc you know and then
our producer said well I know somebody
who knows Mads Mikkelsen I'm like what
doesn't really matter because he would
never say yes he just did
he comes from doing a Casino Royale a
juice yeah Marvel movie Star Wars movie
and no Marvel yes Star Wars - that's
right right he was roped in rogue one
and he was the bad guy and Doctor
Strange yeah there is zero way that he's
gonna want to do this but okay I guess
go ahead and send it to him and yeah so
literally we were running out of time
this is like we have two weeks left
before I give them an ultimatum the
producers like if we don't have our
actor till here we don't have enough
time to produce the film because we're
gonna run out of snow in Iceland so like
literally guys it's two weeks and that
I'm gonna say yes to this job so at this
point pretty much the entirety of Arctic
has been like written ready to produce
it's all ready to go the only thing
you're waiting on is an actor yeah
that's it
you know if we need somebody to say yes
in somebody who like works well we got a
couple other people to say yes who were
like great TV stars and in wonderful
actors who I thought could have pulled
off this film really really really well
but you know that you have to run it
through films like this you have to
pre-sell it in in like jerp so you
basically go to Germany and say hey do
you want to buy this movie now for X
amount or we're gonna sell it to you
later for 3x or 4x once it's done take a
chance on this film yeah you know and
for that they need to be like okay so
who's the director in it oh there's
nobody from YouTube okay no thank you
so they need like a big actor on it and
and yeah so they need a name they need
somebody who they can trust somebody
marketable so it needs to be like a
certain caliber of actor and you know
it's like a Wednesday and I gave him
until the Friday and in like two days
before our cutoff date and I literally
and have written and it's in my drafts
the email to YouTube being like thank
you very much I'll start on Monday
mm-hmm and then on Wednesday they're
like Mads Mikkelsen wants to talk to you
tomorrow
Wow yeah you have a 15 minute Skype call
with him convince him so like they
didn't know this but like it was
literally like if I couldn't convince
him on that Skype call I would have
taken the job the next
they were you nervous the stakes are
high stakes are really high but like I
don't think that that I could be nervous
like it was the same thing with like
later on with like the premiere and etc
people are asking like are you nervous
tonight are you nervous I'm like if
whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen
you know so what were you feeling going
into the Skype call it was like this I
knew that this was gonna be a huge fork
in my life I just didn't know which one
it was gonna be and I was gonna be happy
either way I had already told myself
that I was gonna be happy with the
YouTube job and I was gonna make it work
and I was gonna make that fun you know I
still can do my YouTube channel on the
side because it's you know there plenty
of youtubers who work for YouTube so it
was gonna be like where's it gonna go
you know either this film is gonna get
made and then I'm gonna try to go down
that path or the other way you know and
like my bank account is going see are
you sitting there at you computer like
waiting for the call to happen or did
you call him
are you just saying yeah like alright
any minute now so I Adam on skype right
and I'm at the YouTube space actually
because I was like I need the best
internet connection and I was also doing
like some pickups for a YouTube video
then you know so I just booked extra
time and then I'm in this glass building
so I feel like everyone is like looking
glass office so I feel like everyone's
looking in I tell my partner Ryan
Morrison who co-wrote the film with me
is executive reduced her in the film he
was like I'm just gonna wait outside
right so yeah just you know it should
just be director and an actor he's like
okay cool so he starts pacing outside
and then on skype I had his name I'll
give you guys his name later on and I'm
waiting and he's one minute late and
then he's five minutes late and then
seven minutes into it that's a really
good Skype impression
you know and yeah I get on and and
there's Mads Mikkelsen smoking a
cigarette and and immediately he's like
nice nice script man great script good
great work and I'm like okay alright
okay here we go taking all that ice from
the Arctic and just cracking it in half
that's it you know and then we started
talking and we start talking in 15
minutes goes by and he's like well you
talk about this beginning scene where
you don't see the SOS right so how would
you do that so then I shared my screen
with him and I had done some photo
boards I can't do service I can't draw
you know so I show him the screen and
I'm like this is this is how it is you
know it's like you start from shot like
this not like that so basically it was
other films and like things that I have
found on Google and things like that and
photoshopping like a helicopter into
Gandalf space going like this but it's
the right emotion you know sometimes
there's there's an a continuity of
character there but there's it's like a
continuity of action so then I show him
the first CNN he's like okay keep going
so then I show him the next scene and
the next scene and the next and I'm like
you're good
like you said they said 15 minutes yeah
I'll keep going so we run through the
entire film Orion outside is like
ripping his what's left of his hair I
was like waiting for his child to be
born right so there's an expected phone
call of 15 minutes how long did it ended
up just like three hours later Wow yeah
we're like that the office like was I
only booked it for an hour I was like I
hope no one book that after me and comes
in and like is trying to get the so
thankfully there wasn't anyone there and
then we started talking at the end we
start talking about the themes of the
film he's like this is insane it's a
survival film but you're starting it
after the traumatic event after the
plane crashes he's already learned how
to fish like why are you starting to
swim so late and I told him about why I
thought that that was the best idea and
then you guys you know about ten minutes
later he's like wow I wanna start going
beard okay cool so you gonna do this
homies thing I want to start wearing my
beard let's have our people talk right
and in literally I hung up on the phone
and it's like shoot so I called my
producers who had been blowing me up
because they were like thirty minutes
there's already gone by 40 minutes Cena
so then I called him back and then I get
Ryan to come in and I put everybody else
be her friend I'm like he said he's
gonna start growing his beard it's like
what is he in he's like but he's our
best sounds like he's in I don't know so
then you know all the agents talk and
then yet next day or two days later
we're like man I thought you forgot him
I mean you mentioned briefly uh about
how the film starts and that's something
I actually really liked about it so like
cast away for instance is kind of like
the biggest comparison movie right and
it's like yeah the first like 30 minutes
is all about Tom Lenk Tom Hanks life you
know he's a Fed Ex worker he crashes on
the island he learns how to do all this
stuff and then it cuts to four years
later and when the spear going through a
fish and he's like all grown out yeah
and that's kind of where this movie
starts yeah and I found that really
interesting about this movie it's like
it's just implied it's like oh yeah he's
been out here long enough he knows how
to like survive right and cuz that's not
what I expected going into the movie I
thought was gonna be about him like he
just crashed she's gonna have to learn
about you know surviving in the arctic
cold and all that stuff but it's like
you were very much so like that story's
already been told I'm gonna tell a
different story
yeah I like that you know it I happened
to years and years ago I caught I was
like flipping through channels when I
still had cable and it was like TBS or
something
it was a I flipped to TBS and was a
black screen I'm like oh I'm watching
something catching something coming from
break right and it fades up and yeah
it's a little fish swimming around and
that spear comes in tilts up and it's
Tom Hanks with a giant beard I'm
watching castaway oh yeah I gotta watch
this and then I watched the film through
through there you know and that point
from that point on and like he's holding
a little picture of Helen Hunt I'm like
oh yeah I remember you know so I was I
figuring out the film from there on and
I thought that that was so interesting
that that the film still worked from
that moment on you know okay and I was
like wow that's it so that just kind of
stuck with me
so when Ryan and
we're talking about writing the film I
was like I think that this could work
you know starting this film late and
like what could I say that you can't
picture better you know people like
books better for a reason a lot of the
times it's like well I picture something
different mm-hmm so sometimes I talk to
people later and I'm like what did you
think and some people are like oh I
think that he like had a big fight with
his dad and then drink and that's why he
crashed his plane and some other people
are like well no it's because of there
was a big storm and then he had to fly
around it and then crashed and then you
know he's trying to get back to his wife
and then it's like Oh his daughter has
cancer like so many crazy stories that
people invent and everyone has the best
version of that film in their minds so
if I like give you a story like here's
my story you've already you probably
have something better in you mind did
you come up with the backstory for for
that character yeah how big was the
backstory pages and pages and pages you
know we didn't know whether we had that
we were gonna have an actor who who
needed that you know a lot of actors are
like you know I can't just play out it
against nothing mm-hm and then also not
know where I'm coming from I need to
know but we wrote a bunch of stories
about like what kind of what kind of guy
he was where he came from why he did
this and then you know I had the whole
package like too mad in Iceland and I
was like hey this is the backstory I
want none of this to show up on screen
but do you need it he's like I got my
own story in the shredder he goes now
when you were directing Mads you know
you're a first-time director Mads is a
very accomplished actor mmm-hmm did you
well was the experience like did you
find that he would let you change his
acting or did he kind of call his shots
and you're along for the ride for a
little bit until you built a certain
level of trust yeah you know I when he
first signed on that's what I thought it
was gonna be like this is Mads effing
Mickelson and I I put a camera over here
and I pressed a little button and I say
I don't know action I guess he does what
he does you know he is so great in even
like that the films that to me don't
work well that he's done you know
in really crappy movies sometimes most
isn't Hollywood worth it so so that but
he is constantly wonderful so he must
not be listening to bad directors so so
yeah you know to me it was like he must
just do something but no it was actually
the complete opposite of that was like
really Hodel collaboration and there
were things that he disagreed with they
he was like and you know the producers
would come up to me and there was this
one special moment specific moment that
I can think of where him and I had had a
conversation and I always asked the
actor first like what do you think this
is in case it's better than what I think
you know and then he said what he
thought and I was like I actually think
this other thing he's like okay well
let's do it your way
hmm because I just stressed your opinion
right and then the producers later came
to me and said hey I'm just completely
separate without knowing that we had
talked um they said how about this thing
and then he they said maybe you should
change it to what Mads thought without
knowing that if we had even talked right
and then Mads without me saying anything
cuz I was I wrong you know if everyone's
saying that I should change it then I
should change it the meds without saying
anything he's like no no let's not do
that way let's keep it how it is so like
he's like fighting for me like not even
give me a little wink after you know
yeah I was like wow okay so this guy
trusts my vision and this guy like wants
me to participate in in in what he's
doing how do you feel like you earned
that trust when do you think that trust
happened yeah I think being a co-writer
on the script really helped yeah because
and you know that three hours Skype call
because I won't say that he was testing
me but he was definitely asking
questions that was that were like the
yeah like a litmus
oh I'm fine he was testing me I'm trying
to figure out like like how would you do
this how would you do that yeah I know
and the vision matched like 99% with
what he wanted you know so yeah it was
it was great you know and
it's wonderful to have him in your
pocket you know because sometimes it's
like uh you only have half a day to
shoot the scene it was like I need a
full day to shoot that scene it's like I
were only giving you half a day and then
it's like okay well hey Mads do you
think we need a full day to shoot the
scene has a greater full day unless you
did a full name were there a lot of like
first take first rice or things with
meds or were most of the shots just like
yeah let's do it again
yeah or rather I guess my question is
how often did he nail it first try I can
think of maybe five scenes in the film
where we got a second take okay right
you were just rolling through those
pages and he was 19 days shoot so he
pages the day were you doing it's kind
of weird because the the script only has
72 pages oh so we kind of started
talking about it as we started doing
like pages a day kind of thing in the
beginning but we need a 72 page because
the lack of dialogue it wasn't gonna
like be 72 minutes longer than that so
we started talking about as minutes a
day so we were shooting seven or eight
minutes a day okay
that's pretty fast pace yeah TV show
pace yeah yeah yeah but we were
rehearsing between takes you know so we
do a take here okay move over there and
as they were moving Matt and I would be
rehearse rehearse rehearse rehearse
let's go and unless there was a problem
with focus or sound we wouldn't do it
again Wow yeah I find that when you're
directing a lot of directions just
making decisions yeah not even
necessarily good or bad decisions just
decisions so that things move forwards
yeah can you think back to when you're
making this film what the hardest
decision was he had to make as a
director yeah we had this like I think
the most beautiful place that I've ever
been in my life was this cave in the
glaciers of ice like deep deep deep
secret cave that nobody knew about but
these Scouts had like skirted crevasses
to get us there and I know the scene
you're talking about yeah from Xena the
movie yeah it's also in the end of the
trailer too you know he's he he's inside
of this cave
but it's not the cave that you see in
the film the cave that you see in the
film is this rocky cave and I just
posted on my Instagram stories
hashtag mystery guitar man yeah yeah
that the the cave that I wandered was
this beautiful cave that was exactly
that but made of ice
everything is that you're encapsulated
by this beautiful blue ice and it was
literally like I'm just I don't get like
emotional much at nature I'm like okay
cool trees I was getting emotional in
there I was like it was beautiful when
we scouted her the first time
and then when we we had a fire or
cinematographer and then we we had to
rescale everything again we I we ended
up in that cave again and I Paul I fell
through the ice at the bottom to the
water and like was up to basically my
midriff in is that the thing that men
have yeah I know sometimes in the
English confounds me so better at
Portuguese I'm pretty good at Portuguese
yeah so you know it's the I was like we
need to shoot here we need to shoot here
and then my producer came up with to me
it was like listen if you tell me that
we need to shoot here we'll make it
happen but I think that you're gonna
lose a lot of what you like we can't
shoot here it's it's you know you're
gonna lose so much of the rest of the
other who's gonna take away from other
things that you need to be able to come
here it's like five hours away from
everything else and the ice is dangerous
we get out like wait until the ice
freezes over for you to be able to shoot
here there's another cave that's way
easier that we can just get to and
everybody can be in there and you're not
having to like rappel into the cave you
know yeah that's like how are we gonna
get into her everything that we need our
gear down like we're paddling it down
you know some some of these people
aren't climbers that you know that some
of these people on they're just like
they're just like makeup people who's
just like the best makeup person but
she's 65 years old like yeah like how
are we gonna get her down there
I'm just having to kind of face the
music and be pragmatic and be like ah
you want it but it's not gonna happen
that was the hardest when there were a
lot of things like that in a film like
this low budget and low shoot days you
know but yeah it was that was the
hardest one losing like that beautiful
cuz to me that was just the most
beautiful thing that I've ever seen my
life well the cave you ended up getting
was still pretty sweet let's go it's a
cool cave yeah it's not life-changing
but it's a cool cave do you have
pictures of that cool icy cave mm-hmm I
keep posting them every one snow I'd be
like how much of your life was dedicated
um when did you start writing it like I
assume you had an idea that you'd been
kind of kicking around it for a little
while before you actually opened up a
word doc and started writing yeah it was
back in the word no one writes scripts
in Word which Google Docs had a script
right format yeah so great to collab
like through Google Docs nightmare
scripts I know a partner and I we used
to feed in and we just share our screen
with each other
mm-hmm that's not ideal totally drains
your battery for nothing have you heard
of writer do it I have I don't know I've
never tried it and I've heard of I saw
like one thing about somebody losing all
of that work on write to do it ooh
and I was like totally anecdotal but I
am I've got this whole system where like
it automatically backs up every time I
save it backs up to a Google Drive some
so when that I start a 2016 is when Ryan
and I started writing the film okay
and we wrote a quick you know was about
three weeks or so for us to do on Mars
sent the to our agents and they were
like watch the trailer for the Martian
guys should really do that mm-hmm and
they were like okay well switch the
Arctic took us about a week to to switch
it so with this process from 2016 to now
it's basically three years that you're
looking at yeah looking at this process
do you feel like this is a sustainable
model to make a living off of
so you just did an architect's forever
yeah do you would you be able to live
off that or do you feel like this is
something we need to build up a
foundation before you can make the jump
with Arctic specifically now like I I am
on the red with Arctic with how much
money I spent versus how much money I
got and and and definitely definitely
not this was everyone says like you're
the first film is gonna be a raw deal
and you you never gonna make any money
if it's your first film and absolutely
not and I mean that's just what it was
you know the next film maybe you know I
think as a film director absolutely I
can't I won't be able to just do Arctic
forever I'll have to do an Arctic and
then it's no way and then the next one
and the next one you know kind of grow
the the my my capital as a is a director
mm-hmm so this is more of an investment
in your futures
yeah yeah it's same as the short films
you know like I spent $40,000 on a short
film and I knew that I wasn't gonna make
$40,000 out of Adsense on a single video
yeah but it was something that I knew
could eventually get me Arctic and you
knew that going into Arctic that you
were probably not gonna make any money
off of it yeah yeah exactly I mean you
know just the investment on the short
film if I look at it that way the money
that was getting paid for Arctic did not
cover in that short film that I had made
specifically so that we can get
something like Arctic but hopefully the
next one and the next one well you know
what Arctic is like still in theaters
and it's still like heading towards
distribution when you say like you're
still in the red is that with your
projections on how much money I'm I
always kind of whenever I do my math I
always pretend like it's the worst
possible I pretend like Arctic is gonna
bomb but zero people are gonna go see
him in the theaters and I'm never gonna
see any money out of it so if it does go
out into theatres and like with DVD
sales and blu-rays and etc I'm you know
if I do make any money out of that then
great you know that then it's just bonus
for me so I know a lot of Tony
yeah I've been confused a little bit
yeah I think you know why because
mads mikkelsen starred yeah we called
Arctic but he also starred in another
movie called polar hahaha
and that came out on Netflix so everyone
can be like oh I just draw on Netflix
and watch it I saw a tweet the other it
was like I feel so ashamed of being
Brazilian because Joe Penna directed
this this movie called polar on Netflix
and I hate it
have you seen polar I have yeah I'm
gonna refrain from talking about polar
and my thoughts on it I thought that the
Mads was very great in it
and that's where I'll leave it it's it's
the different kind of film that I would
have made I guess either polar opposites
the dopes he's like an assassin in that
movie or something like that right yeah
I called John wick cold it's it yeah
it's it's like this violent gory like
really crazy crazy film and you know I'm
more of the like the restrained style
you know only show what absolutely you
must show you know right what do you do
you know what Mads thinks of the two
movies like what they're naming and
whatnot yeah you know he was just like
he thought that they were gonna come out
like a year apart basically we all did
you know but the fact that our
distributor held the film - because end
of the year you get all of these like
Oscar release buhbuh buhbuh buzz right
all is lost
released there's a very similar film and
released at the end of the year and it
was kind of lust I mean that kind of
shuffle you know it was great
performance by Robert Redford but you
know they were like mmm we don't want to
go there we want the movie to make money
we want your first movie to make money
smart um so let's release in February
we're here you know January they call it
like the dump month
yeah you just dump movies in January
February is still like kind of sort of
coming out of the dump you know you're
starting to thaw out I don't know
so they're like let's offer the best
film for February
and that's what a lot of the reviews are
saying now it's like this is wow it's so
great to see him a film like I spoke to
a film critic that was like I was about
to quit my job because I was being
forced to watch all these like crappy
dump month movies and then I saw your
film and like I thank you for making a
great film oh that's the nicest thing
that anyone has said Wow
I'm glad that you kept your job what
going to your next project what did you
learn from Arctic that you will be
taking with you
yeah it's hmm question you know well I
was I have been saying like that it's a
it's it's a marathon it's like a
strength of will you know keep going
keep going keep going like day after day
after day after day but now that I think
about it I think I learned that on
YouTube hmm you know it's it's if
especially when you're doing a video on
Tuesday and a video on Thursday and
there a high production value it's on
every day you're working you know every
day you're either answering comments or
editing or rotoscoping or tracking or
doing something you know mm-hmm
but yeah you know it's I learned a lot
how to deal with the politics of of a
film you know it's on YouTube I get
exactly what I want and wait and it's
like I want it this way let's do it that
way but with that with a feature film
it's like okay well the producer wants
this the actor wants this I want this
the line producer who's the guy who's
doing the budget who wanted this you
know so I need to I need to figure out
something that makes everybody happy you
know but still is something that I would
decide for myself
so what what is that it's a little bit
of like it's the they call it a puzzle
you know I think that that's not right a
puzzle there is only one way to put it
together correctly it's more like a lego
thing that you're trying to build you
know out of like yeah out of multiple
different Lego so that's bucket of
random colors it's sitting in your
closet yeah yeah and you trying to you
know make something out of that mm-hmm
and you're never gonna get exactly what
you want you know this it's again
something I learned on YouTube
that was you know really magnified on
the feature film I wanted that cave but
I can't do that cave you know I wanted
this but I can't do that
I've wanted 30 cheating days and we
ended up with 19 yeah was the 19
dictated by the season versus budget a
little bit of both
yeah we lost a lot of days dude weather
you know there was just some days where
it like we got two or three shots and
that was it because that's all we can do
the road is blocked you know it was we
went from from quickly from like 25 from
30 days down at 25 due to budget and
then from the 25 we started whittling it
down because if like oh now there's a
huge there's a huge snowstorm and we
can't get to the location that we wanted
so therefore we got to shoot something
else yeah but half of those props aren't
ready so oh my god okay let's just shoot
what we can't um you know so that's what
it is you know you just end up with 19
full shooting days when when putting
together a budget for a film like this
especially a little bit of film somebody
like Mads Mikkelsen
a big cost or is he more like in it
because he wants to be in it and it's
just another factor with everything else
yeah you know it's it's more the latter
you know it's he of course she's gonna
be the biggest cost of the film but
still it's he deserves in a zero at the
end of it he got you know little films
like this usually what they do it's it's
because they want to do it and they love
it and they some call schedule F which
is like the basically the minimum that a
SAG can pay you
sometimes actors work for that no I'm
but not when you're the only person in
the film of course not you know but like
give and give the guy like multiple
schedule that you would have given to a
bunch of different actors you know but
you know if if they see it as a good
opportunity as something that like if
they want to do that's different or
working with an actor who they've always
wanted to work with a director they've
always wanted Jonah Hill was scheduled
effing Wall Street oh there you go yeah
exactly really yeah he wanted be in a
Leonardo DiCaprio okay work well for him
so yeah so you you take a chance you
know sometimes you know they take more
they call them points in the backend
where it's like okay don't pay me now or
deferments pay me later once the film
makes money multiply I don't know what
his deal was I just left the producers
figured that out but I just know that
that it was less then like Row one yeah
I think just the the catering budget was
you know an extra zero than our budget
in rockland yeah yeah
for somebody wanting to go out and make
a film what would you how would you
suggest they go about doing it hmm I'm
not saying like I'll just go shoot it
but like more in terms like yeah like
hey I want to actually make a real movie
that goes into theaters yeah oh yeah I
see that's interesting you know I I
can't say do youtube because my
producers didn't know that I had a
YouTube channel until I was in Iceland
really making the film yeah they were
like they came up to me and they said
what's this magic guitar thing but you
have on Twitter funny it's funny they're
like no seriously what would you tweet
about this and was that not the reason
why you guys hard because my youtube
channel they're like no we hurt you
because you sent us a link to a good
short film like oh well shoot this like
changes everything okay I got this by
merit okay great but how much did the
YouTube thing help but if at all outside
about just your experience of it
zero yeah yeah didn't help at all I mean
it's helping a lot with them with
marketing the film for sure you know
it's I put up a teaser they got like
almost a million views on on my youtube
channel and like a lot of articles that
have come out about it it's like YouTube
returns can filmmaker
turns theatrical blah blah you know so
it's helped with the marketing for sure
but zero with getting the actual film
but what did help was the short films so
I think that the way to do it is if you
have like a slate of short films that
you're proud of and you have a script
that you've written that you're proud of
because I was sent a lot of scripts
before this before we wrote this
together
and it was like hey take this Viner
turned youtuber
here's 500,000 shoot a horror film in a
cabin for 12 days good luck yeah you
want to do that I was like I don't want
to do that you know because I know that
the very first thing that I do in this
realm I want it to be excellent you know
and I'm not sure that I can make an
excellent film like that you know so
yeah you know it's fine a great producer
if if that's what that's what it is if
you're on the creative side is you have
to find somebody who's gonna like go out
and be fighting for you and be pushing
and be like who do we know who can we
talk to and you know let's let's get an
international sales company and then
we'll get some money from Germany and
somebody from France and somebody from
the UK or whatever maybe and then we
have enough budget to make our film and
then we can sell it for the rest of the
world so that stuff is really intricate
but I have no clue how to do so I had to
find the right person how did you find
that producer I happened to be again at
the use of space I was coming out of
these two space and there was this this
uh this lady there who I hadn't seen in
a long time and she's like oh let's go
get lunch sometime so I was like sure so
then I go and I I and she's like what
are you up to it was like I just heard
this film called Arctic I just switched
it I was like I think I want to shoot in
Iceland I've been looking at pictures of
it and she's like oh Iceland I think I
know a producer who is actually going to
Iceland tomorrow you should meet with
him so then that night we had dinner and
I give him the script and he read the
script on the way to Iceland and then in
Iceland found our production company and
Iceland that day Wow yeah it was like it
all came together really fast Wow yeah
she was like the fates smiled upon you a
little bit it was it was like and it's
scary the number of coincidences that
were necessary for this film to get
produced like I just happened to be
coming out the guy just happened to be
going to Iceland Mads just happened to
know somebody who knew somebody it
happened to have not accepted the new
job yet right I was literally I had
written the email and I wanted my wife
to read it before I sent it like that
was that was that was the thing Holden
exactly okay yeah yeah it was it was
insane it was
it was like this crazy amount of
coincidences just to get to what and
then Mads just happened to be have then
two huge films and was looking for
something little he called it rock and
roll hmm filmmaking he wanted to do a
rock and roll film just like his pusher
days you know that's very first channel
either with Nicholas Whitney Morphin
with like tiny little digital cameras
you know or whatever it was that they
shot with so it was this this insane
amount of coincidences and so how do you
do it I've just get really it's just
like on YouTube you know for you for us
to have made this YouTube channel there
is it an immense amount of work that you
have to put in but then you just have to
get lucky you have to make a video that
that goes viral and you have to you know
start a podcast that supports you and
you have to do all these things and you
have to like be at the edge of space
when when Logan Paul is there and then
you you're like hey you want to be in my
podcast and like you that's how it's
like little by little you're inching
forward with all this work and then you
put the same amount of work in there's a
huge step forward and you don't know if
that huge amount of work that you're
putting is gonna get you like this far
like this far or like actually set you
back because that happens so many times
you know where I I put a lot of work
into something and then people are like
yeah about it you know I was like I'm
gonna unsubscribe from your channel
because this video is so lame that being
said if you don't put in the work though
the chances of being lucky there's zero
those yeah yeah yeah for you to get yeah
you're setting yourself up to be lucky
you know and it really it's kind of like
about who you know
or who you meet you know because I
didn't know anybody who could help me
make this film I didn't have those those
people on my team I didn't I didn't know
anybody was just about I got lucky with
who I met at the right time now I've got
a big project coming up with two
big-name actresses yeah yeah I don't
know if you want to talk about your next
movie sure yeah you know I after Arctic
you know after you have a film like this
and it premieres at a big festival you
get the chance to like send out links
and be like what are you doing next
you know people people get interested so
before Arctic we had written this
screenplay called stowaway
but it was too expensive for a
first-time filmmaker we knew that I
would just wanted to hold onto it and
use it as a writing sample we submitted
it to they called in the nickel
fellowship here in LA it's basically the
Oscars same people who put on the Oscars
the Academy they give like 10
fellowships and money to people to
support him for a year for them to write
a script right it's pretty cool yeah so
thousands of people apply and we made
the top fifty which is pretty cool we
didn't get the money but hey top 50 is
pretty good and that that your name gets
sent around Hollywood when you make the
top 50 of the nickel fellowship so we
started getting a lot of interest for
that made Arctic and then you know the
agency after that was like okay well
you've got something marketable here you
we can sell you let's let's they added
another agent to the team which was
really wonderful
I got a management company that was
that's one of the best ones in LA you
know so all together we were like let's
package this film let's put some some
actors in it started sending out the
script and eventually Anna Kendrick was
interested in the script and which was
interesting because Ryan and I wouldn't
writing we had like Anna Kendrick in
mind he has four parts of the script at
least you know you're like okay great
like getting somebody who like you
thought of before this role is wonderful
so I met with her she mocked my
sunglasses because that's the kind of
person she is and we talked for for a
long time and we knew that we were gonna
be on the same page about the kind of
film that it was that we wanted to make
so she signed out to the film and then
same thing with Toni Collette I had a
phone call with her and she had some
questions about like certain parts of
the script about this thing can we make
that like more important for her and I
was like sure you know and we talked
about like how you were Hurst's and
she's like well for some of these scenes
no I don't want to rehearse and I just
want to like get in there and feel it if
you feel that what happens like in the
moment you know interesting okay yeah
yeah let's I see that and I totally
agreed so then as she signed on to the
film and now we have two more rolls to
cast hmmm oh yeah trying to figure out
who who I'm gonna go to next so what's
the log line for this movie it's
basically
four people on a spaceship headed to
Mars and there's an accident that
happens after they can't turn back to
earth you know and not everybody can
make it all the way to Mars there's not
enough oxygen to get everybody there so
it becomes this lifeboat scenario where
who goes can we fix this and if we can't
how and who are we gonna get to what we
gonna do here you know Jerry Tintin
journey to the moon no never that's a
part of that story too
oh is it yeah you should it's a great
story yeah I'm doing that now you know
I'm right I'm watching all of these
these space films and like submarine
films because I wanted to this ship to
be really tight you know you look tight
I have a giant like in the movie the
Martian they have this really cool big
spaceship they have treadmills on it
they're like chances are the ships going
to Mars aren't even gonna be like @f
that size exactly you know it's like two
or three people instead of like six or
ten people you know unless you VFR
actually we'll see smaller than people
realize it is like all the space that
they keep hyping up inside of it like
it's I mean it's not gonna be a cruise
ship it's gonna have a 90 little room
yeah exactly you know so I want it to be
as realistic as possible like Arctic you
know so I'm talking to like Scott Manley
who's that great right like he's like
sending me he literally just sent me an
email with like all these numbers he's
like well he's doing like so many
kilometers per second you should
actually do like these many kilometers
per second because then he's like he's
like he's never gonna show up in the
film but you should have the math ready
I'm like let's do the math buddy all
these emails coming from like at JPL
nasa.gov all these people like really
helping us to try to make a film
realistic you know that's great I don't
want something like I think passengers
had someone like the best production
design for a spaceship I've ever seen
but like that was meant to be like a
beautiful cruise ship was like his
cathedral ceilings and etc I want this
to be like we're all on top of each
other and we have to figure this out you
know like stumbling over each other's
feet basically okay yeah
and you haven't gone into production off
of that yet we're shooting in June June
ok well that's coming out coming up
we're shooting in Germany we're gonna be
we're gonna be pushing on that film and
want to start traveling there and you're
at least eight yeah do you have a
release date not yet which is good you
know because when you have a release
date for a film like this you know you
start kind of sort of chasing it and
it's it like it's always in vacuum I
know ain't gonna do it or not gonna do
box come to you about so with this you
know the producers are like let's let's
just step back let's make the film that
we want to make and then let's figure
out what we're gonna do with it you know
like is there gonna be a festival film
is it gonna be a wide release film is it
gonna be a small wide it's gonna be a
platform at least where you start in LA
in New York and then sort of grow like
we're doing with Arctic we'll figure out
what we're gonna do with that later they
have an inkling on what they want to do
but it's it's still gonna be like they
want to they want to they want us to
make be able to make the film that we
want this is great that's what you you
can't ask for anything more yeah it's
crazy
mm-hmm now one more thing I want to talk
about Arctic yeah is you guys shot a
polar bear we did you guys have a film
they filmed a polar bear no they sniped
it with I just cuz you always here in
the film industry it's like you never
want to shoot with animals or kids yeah
it's like really hard and then trying to
shoot with the Bears like extra hard but
most people shoot with like a grizzly
bear there's like yeah who have grizzly
bears this guy here right yeah yeah and
what you guys shot with a polar bear
yeah and I want to hear like from the
beginning you guys knew you're gonna
have a bear in the movie I I know a
little bit about the story about like
what led up to making you guys filming a
bear so when we first shot the scene in
Iceland with the polar bear there's this
basically this polar bear that attacks
the cave but it's on the other side of
the wall and it can't get in right or
it's trying to at least so so what's
man's gonna do we from the beginning we
were told do we can't afford a polar
bear like probably not but go talk to
the producers of the
revenant and so we did we had a meeting
general meeting with them and it's like
Oh what do you do but uh you know just
kind of like we call it just the
water-bottle meeting that you offer your
water bottle yeah I say okay great thank
you or whatever going to be and so I
asked I brought the beer you know Mike
oh so so how'd you guys do the bear she
tells me about technically how that was
done and like okay so we have a polar
bear that we're gonna need for our film
she's like oh what's what's your budget
so I tell her a budget and she's like oh
that's close like polar bears a little
harder to do than a grizzly yeah because
of the way that the hair works at cetera
et cetera it's a little translucent so
Grizzlies a lot easier to do CG but okay
we I think we can make it work just pare
down your shots a little bit and halfway
into it we both realized that I had
given her the budget of the film the
polar bear and she goes oh honey no no
no no you can't even get like a still of
a polar bear for that much okay well we
gotta figure something else out so okay
we go and we shoot the scene with like
this paw thing this claw thing that we
had like our biggest art director on set
you know this guy he was like a body
Icelandic bodybuilders so he's about as
big as a polar bear not eight hundred
pounds big but still you know and he's
like pretty scary on set you know I'm
like oh this might work and then Ryan is
putting the scene together and he's
cutting it together at work you know
doesn't work it's the only time in the
film that we break his perspective if we
were to go outside and show the polar
bear but what are we gonna do like we
can't we can't do it so I'm like okay I
have an idea so I go on YouTube and I'm
like I'm gonna find some like footage of
polar bears and because we come from
YouTube and we have VFX experience and
we can make it something happen right we
can license some National Geographic
footage so I find this this polar bear
attacking walrus right I'm like okay
let's rotoscope on my own and just put
them in our film and it's a National
Geographic documentary that they found
so we do that and and poor Ryan has like
frame by
frame rotoscope furry polar bear but you
know horrendously horrendously yeah
rotoscoping hair is probably the easiest
view not at all it's like the hardest
thing ever is the only harder thing is
like snow in front of the camera which
we had to do sometimes but anyway so so
we put the polar bear into the scene and
sing you know it's it sort of works you
know but that the timing of it works
really well
but as I was searching for that footage
I found a video of a guy swimming in a
swimming pool with a polar bear and I'm
like so I I find his name and I track
him down and I like yellow pages him you
know and I call it and I'm like hey um
mark he's like a mark I'm like um you
pull a bear you have he's like yeah yeah
I've got a polar bear and I was Canadian
nice super nice yeah and and I'm like um
does it like do things he's like you're
gonna have to be like way more specific
because I thought that I had called like
eighteen of the guys with the same name
so like I'd forgotten all my questions
by then and I was like oh okay cool so I
have this shirt this this feature film
I'll be real with you it's a feature
film short film always gets a little
discount but you know alright fine it's
a feature and you know we need a polar
bear for it and I basically need her to
like kind of sort of like try to attack
a cave is just something she's like oh
but she's 22 years old I'm like oh she's
just like no bears usually live until
like they're 20
you know she's relatively old she's like
she has been in commercials before but
you know she's she takes it easy
nowadays you know I'm like oh okay um
well we have this like indie film it's
like a survival film he's like way like
survival films and that was like it so
basically only one person on screen the
whole time he's like oh I like that kind
of film who's the actor and
interestingly enough in the u.s. I
usually have to be like it's Mads
Mikkelsen
he's the guy from christina rail he's
the guy from Hannibal he's the guy from
rogue one and be probably cause I love
that guy whereas in Europe it's
it's Mads Mikkelsen people are like yeah
they know him by name but in the US it's
like unless you're a gamer and you're
can't wait for death stranding or like
here or something like that
or you're a huge Hannibal fan or like
you really love Casino Royale you know
his face ya know which is what we needed
for for the level of notoriety you know
somebody who's huge in Europe so I say
it's Mads Mikkelsen he's and I'm ready
for my spiel and he goes oh my god
that's my favorite actor I think we can
make this work so then he sends me a
budget I'm like we can't make this work
ah how much can you afford
so then I send him as a joke I like
literally just like cross out one of the
zeros ha ha you know as the text message
saying he's like alright welcome a cab
oh wow oh great let's make a handsome so
so then yeah we I find I put together a
whole budget have the guys who did like
the caves for Prometheus in Vancouver
she happens to be near Vancouver which
is great we have like people there you
know he gives me all these stipulations
like you can't have food in the stage
for like two weeks prior because
otherwise she will smell it and she
won't find it and she'll be upset I'm
like oh ok so we can't shoot at a stage
then because we can't hire a stage out
for two weeks and a day you know we
can't for that so we found this like
paper warehouse that was willing to so
like kind of let us turn into stage like
if you let my kids come see the polar
bear yeah I'm like ok cool it's it's you
won't you be surprised with how many
people just want to do cool things yeah
yeah like dads just want to do cool
things this these people who were just
want to do cool things there's value in
cool things yeah you know and and I like
sent a link to the film to like the guy
who is the production designer in and of
prometheus and he's like oh cool yeah
I'll build you cave I'll have my art
director build your cave yeah for sure
what we'll do it a cost you know so it's
all of those little things kind of sort
of add up to be able to do a polar bear
for really really cheap so then we show
what we still need it's cheap but
still like six figures you know hmm we
need we need to produce her approval so
we just don't tell them that we've added
the polar bear to the film we play them
the film the entire film from back to
they haven't seen anything right we show
them the and then we have the National
Geographic bear they're right in it at
the end of the film they go oh wow
Wow like that's that worked really well
guys like the whole film is so beautiful
etc etc complements complements the
polar bear what are we gonna do a
buffalo very we can't
what would what's that so then I pull
out a budget and I'm like we can do it
for this much and it's like way cheaper
than then the CG polar bear that
everybody had been thinking about and
they're like to their credit they were
like ah that's gonna be expensive but
yeah we need it let's do it let's do it
it would be in the trus it'll be worth
it that's great yeah so we did it we
went out and crazy stipulations like we
needed real snow that was way more
expensive otherwise she steps she
destroyed us at one time because it was
fixed now and she was forget this and
back into her trailer I couldn't speak
to either her or her trainer at any
times so you know I had to speak to the
trainer's wife and then the wife had to
like whisper to the trainer yeah I mean
that sounds kind of like a weird thing
but at the same time it's like you're
dealing with the real polar bear these
things are our enemies yeah it's a
hundred pounds you know we we it's like
all of these crazy things we're shooting
in August which means that we have to
bring in three dump trucks worth of ice
in order to make enough snow for her Wow
yeah yeah and also there can't be a lot
of people on set and I'm like well I
need somebody like I need a stand-in to
be wearing mantas parka
he's like looks like you're gonna be
doing it so then I put on the park and
he's like oh just act scared I'm like I
don't have to act scared reacting scared
and it was it was like okay we got what
we needed we shut the whole thing you
guys will appreciate this we shot the
whole thing at like 240 frames per
second oh yeah
because most people are like oh you got
to under crank the shot you know so
shoot it at 12 frames per second and
then speed up to 24 and then it'll look
like she's faster than she actually is
but if you should have like 240 it gives
you a bunch of options to actually speed
it up however you want and then you just
add your motion blur in later yeah yeah
smart yeah how many people missed that
with under cranking it's like if you
under if you should have fight scene at
22 frames per second you're stuck you're
stuck at 24 yeah
yeah yeah yeah whereas if you shoot it
at like way more than what you need yeah
then you know you can get really really
close there all of these mathematical
things that you can like you can speed
it up by exactly 80% exactly 50% exactly
25% you know yes they'll be perfect
where you're falling on a frame that
temporarily was there yeah I know drop
frames or anything like that or you
having like interpolate between rhymes
when they're 60 yeah then you don't you
have zero motion blur so there's a
problem called real smart motion blur
that you can take and I love real smart
motion blur around since like right 99
incredible hagh like if real smart is
running on a computer don't do anything
else to it
you don't like gonna blow up and turn
into a black hole this is sort of thing
that I turn on right before I render the
shot so did you did you struggle to get
the polar bears and actually do the
beats that you needed or was that pretty
straightforward well so she she has a
couple tricks right um this is gonna
totally ruin the film for a lot of
people but I'll do it anyway ruin it so
she doesn't roar i I asked the guy like
should I bring a sound person you know
and and record her roar he goes oh no
she doesn't roar if she roars there's
something like massively going wrong run
because there's something there's
something that's gonna happen and like
okay so then how do how to get her dead
roar up so you know roar and a
commercial before it's like okay what I
do is I have like a little stick and I
say smile smile smile and she goes oh
good bear
got bear look the whole thing was so
positive yeah that were actually had to
start acting scared because I'm like and
yeah so so we add the roar in later yeah
yeah and I was doing that like in bed
next to my wife and she was trying to
read a book and she's like take your
headphones off I can hear you like stop
I can hear the bear like I'm trying to
read it okay I'll turn it down yeah so
so anyway it was like that but then the
worst thing was that it was August so
the snow was melting so we had to keep
refreshing the snow and you know it like
it's he gives you like a arranged like I
think I'm gonna be able to get already
between 30 and 45 minutes right so we
were doing the math okay 30 to 45 let's
kind of during the math and she was
ready in 28 minutes say you know so
there was a little too much snow there's
a little hole that she's supposed to put
her head through and there's a tree on
the other side for her so then she gets
up on on the snow she's like oh no she's
like loving it and she kind of like lies
down on the snow and she was super cute
and fluffy I don't good scary scary
scary go you know and then she kind of
gets up and she realizes there's a whole
interesting I see what's in there and
then the trainers on the other side it's
like come here come here
come on there's a treat for you over
here and then she like tries to put her
head through and she can't hmm
and she goes okay I have through this
way and she can't yeah and then the
trainer turns to me and is like this is
gonna be a problem she starts going
she's not supposed to roar ever Oh
I mean she starts going like this I try
to do the snow and I'm like to the
camera guys I'm like yeah yeah yeah it's
like okay good and she's so first she
starts pacing back and forth in the
scene and she's not she can't get in and
she's upset
right so literally this was happening
the only issue is that you actually have
an 800-pound beast that's angry in front
of you you know and like you're the one
who's closest to her and this is like
when she climbs on top of it I mean like
like does that whole smackdown thing
that she does right and and then she
starts like she finally is able to like
home kind of like put it through and
then he goes smile smile I should go
tell it there's a snarl to the smile you
know and there was like a little bit of
shouts at the smile they're supposed to
be like oh my god and I'm right there
like pretending to be scared but I'm
actually scared and okay okay get out
yeah and then she goes back to her
trailer there's a little wading pool in
there for her mmm little a pool in this
40-foot long trailer any closes right
and gives her a nice Street cuz when she
goes into the trailer she gets the nice
treats and he closes the door Ian looks
at me he's like you got that anything
else
I was like yeah and there any I was it
was good she was a she was a good sport
about it
that's really exciting yeah how many
cameras are you using or are you rolling
on we had let's see we the only thing
that we were shooting read that the rest
of it was Alexa so we had one two three
and then four four like a little tiny
camera that was like just the DPS camera
then we ended up not using it but it
turned out to be cool for like behind
the scenes kind of thing hmm
yeah dude the shot where the bear was
like literally sticking her head through
the hole and you see it from the other
side it's just like this this snowy wall
in a bear head just with the gaping maw
yeah that was like oh my god that's a
real bears a real bear right yeah you
know one reviewer said the film was good
everything was good about the film was
all great but the CG bear was just so
over the top
adding little like spit inside of her
mouth it was way like completely
unbelievable I don't think but uh yeah
if props to the editor for that you know
Ryan who edited the film because we had
already shot the stuff with Mads so
basically the bear had to hit her marks
mm-hmm and that's not possible so ho you
know like he found little bits of we're
like Mads looks up and then she's
climbing on top you know and then man
looks back down like you know like we've
analyzed almost frame by frame that
footage to be able to figure out how to
like marry these two people who weren't
playing against each other together to
make it seem like they were in the same
room you know and then we got some
pickups here in LA Christian was a I
think Christian was was part of it yeah
oh no it was a Alex who had been working
for me for a while
um and and Carolyn so in LA we got some
green screen stuff it's the only green
screen shot in the whole film is isn't
me so yeah it was uh turned out to be
good I think it I think it works you
know people actually think that Mads was
there yeah yeah so you guys asked the
butter in every interview like Oh was it
like working with the Bears I wasn't
there I was shooting a film called polar
[Laughter]
with no polar bears ironically no yeah
so so we want to watch Arctic how could
they watch Arctic it's really nice
having a distributor because they do all
these like nice things you know they set
up two websites for us Arctic movie calm
or you can see like the release schedule
on the fifteenth two days from now this
Friday you know we're gonna be opening
in a bunch of other theaters new
theaters we've been playing in Boston la
Chicago New York so still in those
cities and then opening in a bunch more
so Arctic movie.com
and then they all set up a different web
cycle Arctic movietickets.com where you
can just like search for your city and
see if you can buy those tickets they're
interesting okay it's nice it's like
it's not something that I would have
done from my own film you know cuz I
don't know long am I gonna spend like
the money on to domain names
but yeah you know yeah now are you only
thinking about theater distribution for
now what about like once the theater
runs gone are you gonna try to like get
it on Netflix or some sort of streaming
platform yeah they have they have a
whole plan for it right so the like this
week we're opening up in a bunch of
theaters then next week or the next one
hopefully we get to go like nationwide
depending on how many people go to see
it this week so it's very important that
people go see it right now that it's
like you know some people have been like
oh I'll go see it next week I'm like can
you go see it this week go to Arctic
movie tickets calm everybody it's it's
funny to not be promoting mystery guitar
man anymore yeah it kind of becomes
project-based promotion you know but but
yeah so it's it's like basically every
they said that every one ticket that
sells for the first week means like 10
or 20 tickets down the line because more
theaters for example our opening weekend
was like the worst opening weekend in 20
years for films no no no for all films
in general films was that because there
is a massive polar vortex coming through
and the Superbowl and as oh yeah yeah
you know but still our film would have
like fourteen thousand dollars per
theater average which is huge it's
insane insanely huge so despite it being
like like overall not great money it's
still like the the CEO of the oblique
you should call me it was like this is
great I'm like I said no it's great like
we're you know opening in more theaters
next week and you know Regals and AMC's
aren't interested because it you you
were the best of like the the people who
got EPS
basically everyone everyone got an F
that weekend but you got an F plus but
it's it was important you know like
there were Q&A is that people came to
and and all the reviewers are saying is
really really nice things about it you
know the people on like NPR said like
you must go watch this film you know so
it there were this also of varied types
of people like really old people came
because of the radio things and like
there's a 12 year old who came up to me
after the
I said this was my favorite film of all
time that's awesome watch more films
when I saw it in the theater I was
sitting next to a very old couple they
had to have been in their 80s and the
woman just she kept they weren't I
wouldn't call them jump-scares in the
movie but there are moments of just kind
of like like surprise yeah she would
like literally jump out of her chair
legs went up over her head like over
heads yeah yeah it's just like oh okay
oh my gosh that's that scares me yeah
it's an eighty-year-old it's like their
pacemaker going I'm like just like
you're right okay we're good okay yeah
yeah you know I've set in like at the
very very back row I don't want people
like seeing me there you know I just
kind of like do this on the way in you
know and just to see the audience
reaction and like when you show a nasty
cut or something and people going to
like throw out you know forgot you guys
had some amazing practical makeup in
that oh yeah as much as we could we
never they likely they were very
convincingly like that as a gash and it
looks like that's an actual gasps yeah
yeah yeah
our makeup person was really really
wonderful this this our makeup director
or lead makeup person I guess it's what
they called uh was like the best in
Iceland and had been such huge films and
she had like an apprentice that was was
her first film so she made sure that
everything was perfect that it's gonna
be perfect you know just like I was
trying to do so it was it was great
having that that kind of Cromartie onset
that's awesome it's really fun filming
really good practical like wounds yeah
remember with lifeline we had to have a
shot with me sticks a knife under the
skin in the forearm like anything out
it's the guy I don't set up and like the
blood tubes running in but you couldn't
see any of it especially oh the tubes -
yeah it's fine you're not trying to like
tie and make it look like but it's so
gross washing a completely realistic
like seeing something just like taking
this blade and just shoving it under
their skin and once that's pouring out
it's like yeah I can get a little
squeamish sometimes and I was like it
looks good no it's fake I know I can see
like a hand it's gonna have to be
painted out later you know like doing
little kind of thing yeah but like it's
it's you know you're
rain is just like it's real it's real
I'm looking at a gash you know yeah yeah
but it's like it was it's literally like
half a second in the film that we like
just flash it because I didn't want to
be gory gory film yeah yeah for half a
second I flashed the gash in I can
totally now see why people do horror
films because that it's like one of the
bigger reactions of the film people are
like oh my god oh okay it's god yeah
make you feel something yeah you know I
totally see why people do like films
that I are just like blood going
everywhere and crazy wounds and it's
just all so fun on set being like oh
that looks gross yeah that's awesome
yeah Joe thanks for coming out thank you
for having me guys this is really fun
yeah it was a fascinating journey that
you took us along with like hang about
the polar bear or like heck sound like
the most important Skype call of your
life yeah that was the most important 15
to 3 hours call yeah like straight up
there are alternate universes now or
like a very huge chunk of them you're
working at the YouTube space alright
it's like that was just such a defining
split yeah yeah there's an alternate
universe where the internet goes down at
the YouTube space for some reason and
I'm working there now you know and I'm
happy I'm happy
I'm telling myself that I'm happy yeah
and I'm figuring it out you know oh yeah
now now you know it's it's it's so and
it's great having the support of the
community on this you know like you guys
coming out for for the opening night and
having me on your podcast and you know
these youtubers like being proud that
I'm I'm one of them and like hash tag
teaming and that kind of thing and it's
it's so it's so good to be like oh these
are friends I have friends I haven't
devoted myself entirely to me my craft
thank you Joe
well I hope you all enjoyed listening to
that corridor cast here with Joe Penna
it was a fascinating conversation a lot
of really interesting
stuff shared if you haven't checked out
Arctic once again go check it out go
send them a tweet tell them it's awesome
that I did a project like this I'm sure
he'll appreciate it and if you're not
subscribed to the corridor cast here in
YouTube please do consider subscribing
we're also found anywhere you want to
listen to podcast whether it's iTunes
Spotify and whatever else is out there
you name it we're on it
so go check it out yeah more stuff on
the way people hit that Bell hit that
like button tell us tell us what your
favorite part of this episode was engage
in some discussion we love hearing your
thoughts down below alright
can't wait to see you on the next one
thank you